[Music]
on this sunday night scaling back the
federal subsidy during a labor shortage
the government's plan to get people back
to work and keep businesses running
we're really trying to put in place
active measures like the hiring program
the wage subsidy that incentivize work a
step towards normal health restrictions
are about to ease in two provinces plus
a double weather bomb get ready for wild
weather on the west coast
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us canadian businesses are bracing for
changes to benefits that have kept them
in operation throughout the coven 19
pandemic the federally funded programs
are winding down this weekend after 18
months and billions of dollars spent
many companies are no longer eligible
for the retooled subsidies still on the
table and business owners say they're
left in a perilous position as abigail
beeman explains ottawa is moving from
broad financial backstops to a more
targeted approach
if the birds and the bees refers to the
facts of life our sales are still quite
a bit down at vancouver's the birds and
the beets cafe those facts are stark
sales are down but not low enough to
meet the federal government's new 40
percent threshold for the wage subsidy
at the end of this help you know our
survival is really in jeopardy the
restaurant lobby group calls the
benefits retooling a death sentence for
many members while the canadian center
for policy alternatives estimates in
total more than a million and a half
workers could be affected most of whom
don't have another source of support we
really needed to move to a more targeted
approach that really focus on the
sectors that haven't recovered top of
the list of hardest hit industries
offered help are tourism and hospitality
that includes restaurants they have a
lower bar to qualify and can get more
money as many sectors face staff
shortages the government is also
extending the hiring program and
boosting the subsidy rate on the west
block the employment minister
acknowledged they could be doing a
better job of getting out the message
that the underused hiring program exists
we're really trying to put in place
active measures like the hiring program
the wage subsidy that incentivize work
and aren't as passive say as the crb was
there have been complaints the original
serb made it more attractive to stay
home that narrowed to the crb which is
now ending replaced by a hyper-localized
300 a week lockdown benefit for workers
who may find themselves temporarily off
the job i think there's a lot of hope
that this is going to have an effect but
i think
the reality is it's not going to be that
helpful a lot of people have moved on
from these industries they just don't
intend to go back the government has set
aside more than seven billion dollars to
spend on pandemic supports between now
and next may but this is a minority
parliament after all meaning the
liberals will have to get an opposition
party onside to make their plan a
reality when the house returns late next
month abigail b men global news ottawa
for a look at which benefits are
expiring or changing go to our website
globalnews.ca
global national
parts of bc and ontario will see
capacity limits ease as of midnight
tonight but doctors warn no area of the
country is out of the woods yet and if
there's one province to keep an eye on
it may be saskatchewan as heather york's
west explains the situation unfolding in
the prairie province could serve as a
cautionary tale
in saskatoon saturday thousands attended
the concert of country music star eric
church and though everyone had to show
proof of vaccination in the midst of a
punishing fourth wave the crowded venue
images provoked concern i wouldn't be
surprised if there is a
multiple outbreaks you know happening
that is
you know that is associated with that
concert last night saskatchewan has had
no gathering or capacity limits in place
since the summer something many in the
medical community have been pushing to
change as the province now sends
critically ill patients to ontario it's
a stark contrast to the situation
elsewhere in ontario and bc where many
public health measures have remained in
place well into fall this week venues in
metro vancouver and on vancouver island
will finally return to full capacity in
terms of the larger venues we were the
holdouts with respect to the rest of
canada so it would have required a very
significant and convincing explanation
to not do it so in that context i think
it is the right step at this time
ontario is also lifting business
capacity restrictions this week that's
not unreasonable with a huge caveat that
if we start to see things headed in the
wrong direction you've got to scale
things back a little bit ontario is now
looking towards the end of all
restrictions easing vaccine passport
requirements beginning in january a
change alberta's open for summer premier
is not rushing towards we think the
program is working well
it will be in place at least until the
first quarter of next year we'll assess
it then
based on uh coveted trends here and
around the world when it comes to this
pandemic no two jurisdictions have
handled things the same way but after a
disastrous autumn across much of the
west canada's winter months will
undoubtedly demand some caution heather
yurix west global news calgary
the world's most locked down city has
reopened residents of melbourne
australia flocked to pubs restaurants
and hair salons over the weekend after
some coven 19 restrictions were lifted
in addition to many indoor venues
reopening masks are no longer required
outdoors the five million people who
live there have endured nearly nine
months of restrictions during six
separate lockdowns since march 2020 more
restrictions are expected to be dropped
on friday when the state is expected to
reach its 80 percent double dose
vaccination target
a new lockdown is looming in russia
which reported its sixth consecutive day
of record deaths over a thousand coven
19 related deaths were recorded today
there are over 35 000 new cases of the
virus as well moscow will reimpose a
lockdown starting thursday with only
essential shops open a nationwide
workplace shutdown begins in november
russian president vladimir putin blames
low vaccination rates for the increase
in fatalities only 36 percent of
russians are fully vaccinated
the west coast of canada and the u.s is
bracing for what's being called a bomb
cyclone the weather system is building
over the pacific ocean and moving
quickly southwestern bc is already
seeing intense winds and rain while
california a state suffering from severe
drought could get 300 millimeters of
rain residents there are bracing for
flash flooding hurricane-force winds and
major mudslides jennifer johnson has the
latest
weather whiplash in california heavy
rain is pouring down on a state scorch
by three years of severe drought
experts are warning of widespread flash
flooding and mudslides because the land
won't be able to absorb the rain coming
from atmospheric rivers described as a
fire hose of moisture officials are
warning residents to be prepared if they
say evacuations i'll just get the hell
out of dodge
ahead of the storm californians lined up
for sandbags to protect their properties
flood barriers were set up in downtown
san francisco unusual sites after
california's governor declared a drought
emergency for the entire state just last
week the bomb cyclone will also pack
heavy winds equivalent to a category 3
hurricane and waves up to 9 meters high
the coast guard is on alert people are
trying to watch you know mother nature
from shore we want to make sure that you
give it enough distance the waves have
these sneaker waves and they can come
get you and and pull you out way too far
in that freezing water
the coast guard is also trying to secure
dozens of container ships parked out at
sea unable to get into west coast ports
because of labor shortages
in northern california the storm is
expected to drop up to 2.5 meters of
snow british columbia is bracing for an
unprecedented fear of storm it's not
only the strength of the winds it's the
period it's a prolonged period of these
strong gusty conditions a day and a half
possibly two full days of very strong
winds so we're not ruling out the
possibility of power outages downed
trees down power lines
storm surge localized flooding all of
these things so this is a big one for us
while this storm could bring widespread
destruction experts say it will have an
upside this will pretty much put an end
to the risk of major fires in northern
california
this has been one of the worst wildfire
and drought seasons in california's
modern history and will likely end
sooner than expected but now there's the
threat of other weather-related
tragedies californians are desperate for
rain but not this much this fast
jennifer johnson global news washington
a cargo ship headed to vancouver fell
prey to a bomb cyclone thursday when
rough seas pushed 40 of its shipping
containers overboard today's weather
system nearly threatened crews trying to
put out a fire on the ship flames broke
out on the mv zim kingston yesterday
while anchored near victoria two
containers are carrying hazardous
materials most crew members left the
ship but five stayed on to help fight
the blaze the coast guard says most of
the fire has now been put out a hazmat
team has been mobilized to the site air
quality monitoring is
set up or setting up on shorelines and
on vessels to monitor contaminants
and there's no concern of harm to
islanders from the fire
both american and canadian coast guards
are still trying to recover the lost
containers they say today's bomb cyclone
could complicate efforts boaters in the
region are still being warned there's a
risk of hitting the floating cargo
troubling details are surfacing about a
crew member involved in the fatal
shooting during the filming of a movie
starring alec baldwin assistant director
dave halls was identified in court
documents as the person who handed the
actor a prop gun and declared it was
safe when it wasn't hall's safety on set
has been called into question before he
was the subject of complaints dating
back to 2019. two people who worked with
him say halls had a disregard for safety
protocols for weapons and pyrotechnics
they also say he complained about having
guns inspected by a professional on set
during a rehearsal for the movie rust
baldwin accidentally shot and killed
helena hutchins last night a vigil was
held for the 42-year-old filmmaker close
to 200 mourners gathered to pay their
respects many are calling for better
safety on sets
there are so many protocols when you're
on set
it almost becomes a ceremony every time
that you are handed a gun to use
obviously something failed
and i don't know what failed but the
fact that this happened shows that
an elemental piece of that safety
protocol
didn't work the production of rust has
been suspended indefinitely new mexico's
occupational health and safety bureau is
investigating
a key border crossing between
afghanistan and pakistan has briefly
opened three weeks after the taliban
ordered it closed
crowds descended on the crossing which
was temporarily reopened allowing people
stuck on either side of the border to go
home the closure of the border led to
violence earlier today afghans stranded
on the pakistani side threw rocks at
border security and law enforcement
authorities sprayed tear gas the
crossing was originally shut down over
fears there would be an influx of
afghans headed to pakistan after the
taliban takeover
no deaths are being reported after an
earthquake struck taiwan
the 6.5 magnitude quake struck midday
shaking buildings in the capitol seconds
later it was followed by a 5.4 tremor
one woman was injured from rocks falling
in a national park authorities
temporarily suspended public transit
coming up one d.c business offers a pay
bump for the dish pit
and bearing it all to put a spotlight on
climate change the provocative display
later on global national
the quebec government has unveiled
controversial new changes to its school
curriculum it will be introducing a new
course that will focus on quebec culture
and citizenship it replaces the ethics
and religious culture program which has
been in place since 2008. quebec
nationalists were critical of that
program arguing it promoted
multiculturalism instead of quebec
values however teachers are worried the
new one will present a narrow view of
quebec society and mute minority voices
so this is kind of just sprung upon us
and the expectation is that we just you
know we're just going to comply well it
doesn't work that way and if the
minister hasn't understood that then he
needs to brush up on the section 23
cases that have come out recently
the new program will be taught in some
schools next year as part of a pilot
project by 2023 it should be in all
elementary and secondary schools across
the province
canada's restaurant industry says it was
short 60 000 workers before the pandemic
now that number has doubled hungry to
hire staff one bc business stepped up to
the plate the pay for the gig may
surprise you but as a matagahi explains
it's a sign that minimum wage may not be
enough to lure employees
it's a quaint local restaurant described
by some as perhaps one of the best
indian restaurants in vancouver
but on friday it was something
completely off the menu placing the
handy grill in news articles and rented
streams across the country
the industry calls this area of a
restaurant the dish pit
a job that always needs more credit to
restaurant operations and apart from
this
there's not much room for creativity or
let's face it career advancement which
is why a job at hondy grill advertised
with permanent full-time status little
experience
and a more than modest salary surprised
people because of its title line that's
why i guess it's very newsworthy because
no that's certainly not the case that
someone's going to be paid 25 an hour to
wash dishes but i think it reflects just
how
desperate our industry is right now to
attract labor according to a recent
restaurants canada survey of its members
nine out of ten canadian restaurants say
they could use more staff
admittedly employers have come to accept
that paying workers minimum wage in this
industry may be a thing of the past but
the salary offered for the dishwasher
position at the hondy grill is still
raising eyebrows if you're a fifty
thousand dollar as a dishwasher that's
the entry job what are you gonna pay
your second cook what are you going to
be your first cook chef to party sous
chef and keep going up until the chef
that mean that i'm charging you 95 to
100 for a plate of salmon it's
impossible to sustain now i had a brief
conversation with the owner and perhaps
she's tired of the publicity and didn't
want to do an interview but did say that
the job has been filled
and that ad no longer exists
and matagahi global news
still ahead what's behind the big c bump
in humpback whales
they're back sheep bells rang out in
spain's capital where locals welcomed an
annual tradition it allows shepherds to
guide their livestock south for the
winter using an ancient migration route
through downtown madrid the yearly event
started in 1994 but was canceled last
year because of the pandemic
a mystery is unfolding off the west
coast but it's one researchers are
welcoming the number of humpback whale
calves spotted near british columbia and
washington state this year has nearly
doubled that of last year kylie statton
has more on the baby boom and what may
be driving it
they're everywhere
incredible it's being called the
humpback comeback
the number of whales making their way to
the salish sea on the rise for the past
two decades but this year a new record
just the sheer number of babies that
we're seeing in 2021 is something that i
certainly was not expecting going into
this season according to the center for
whale research 21 calves have been
photographed and documented throughout
inland washington and british columbia
that's the highest annual number on
record for the region surpassing 2020
when 11 calves were born so we're almost
double what we had last year and last
year was a really great year as well it
all started with big mama the first
whale documented back in 1997.
since then the species has been
migrating each summer to feed in the
nutrient-rich waters off bc's coast
slowly rebuilding the population that
really seems to be what it is is as
humpbacks rediscover the area others are
following them and there seems to be
enough food here to entice them to make
it a regular part of their migration
fall is peak of humpback whale activity
in the salish sea their last feeding
opportunity before swimming roughly 5
000 kilometers to their breeding grounds
near hawaii mexico and central america
where they mate and give birth before
making their return
and if there's a calf in toe naturalists
breathe a collective sigh of relief
because you never know right if both mom
and calf are going to make it back there
are several theories behind the
resurgence that is the million dollar
question it's possibly linked to an
abundance of food for the whales or it
could be as simple as the growing adult
whale population producing more calves
but one thing is certain their presence
creates a hazard for those on the water
and boaters need to not only be aware
but also keep their distance legally it
is 100 meters but 200 meters can keeps
things much simpler as well after all
the better protected they are the better
researchers can track the trend kylie
stanton global news
up next the naked truth about earth from
the lens of an artist
here's one more accolade for canadian
olympian maggie mcneil she was named
best female athlete at the tokyo
olympics by the association of national
olympic committees mcneil competed at
her first olympic games this past summer
and was it ever a triumph she won gold
in the 100 meter butterfly
silver in freestyle relay and bronze in
the medley relay
well done in one week the u.n climate
conference known as cop26 will get
underway in glasgow scotland the goal of
this summit is to deliver a new
agreement to significantly limit
greenhouse gas emissions and stave off
the worst effects of human-caused
climate change while world leaders are
wrangling over targets artists are doing
their part to open the world's eyes to
the reality of our environment as mike
truly explains one photographer is
laying those concerns bare with his
provocative masterpiece
on a rocky hillside overlooking the dead
sea american artist spencer tonic took a
stand against climate change as only he
can
from the roof of a camper he
photographed 200 nude models all painted
stark white
i'm going to be
using
and working with the brave participants
to form
salt pillars
which reference
the
salt pillars formed by springs
in the dead sea
when fresh water enters the dead sea
which we need a lot of tonic first
visited the dead sea a decade ago for an
art installation involving a thousand
nude models five years after the fact
all that was left was crusty sand
because the dead sea which at 430 meters
below sea level is the lowest point on
earth is seeing its water recede by
roughly a meter every year in part
because israel and jordan have diverted
much of the water that feeds into the
dead sea for agriculture and human
consumption it's a really important
treasure here in the middle east and
it's going to disappear really quite
soon if we don't act now so it was very
important for us to come here and
participate in this
provocation of an art show
art as a tool to highlight climate
change has become popular in recent
years in florida panthers melting in the
sun eventually revealed a message more
heat less wildlife
and off the coast of scotland horizontal
lights installed on rocks and buildings
are meant to show the dangers of rising
sea levels
like tonic's nude installations the goal
is to shock and create something world
leaders can't ignore
microlight global news toronto and that
is global national for this sunday night
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
the moon rising over the spirit sands
near brandon manitoba please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
and until next weekend have a great week
[Music]
you